[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Jon: WELCOME BACK TO THE
PROGRAM.
OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS AN ONGOING
SITUATION. FOR MORE ON THE ISSUE
IN FERGUSON, MISSOURI, WE
TURN TO SENIOR MISSOURI
CORRESPONDENT MICHAEL CHE.
MICHAEL, TALK TO US VERY
BRIEFLY.
WHAT IS THE MOOD ON THE STREET
RIGHT NOW IN FERGUSON.
>> BEATS ME, I'M NOT THERE.
THERE ARE TOO MANY WHITE COPS
WITH ITCHY TRIGGER FINGERS IN
FERGUSON.
I'M STAYING RIGHT HERE IN ST.
LOUIS WHERE IT'S SAFE.
[LAUGHING]
>> Jon: ACTUALLY -- I MEAN --
I'M PRETTY SURE IN ST. LOUIS
POLICE ACTUALLY SHOT AND KILLED
A GENTLEMAN, A BLACK GENTLEMAN
THREE DAYS AFTER
THE FERGUSON SHOOTING. SO...
>> WHAT, YOU MEAN LIKE IN A
DIFFERENT ST. LOUIS?
>> Jon: NO, I'M PRETTY SURE IT'S
THE ONE IN MISSOURI.
I THINK IT'S UH...
>> WELL, THAT'S INTERESTING.
Jon: NO, BUT THIS IS, LET ME
TELL YOU SOMETHING, MICHAEL.
THIS IS GOOD. BECAUSE I CAN ASK
YOU ABOUT THE ST. LOUIS COUNTY
POLICE, AND THAT... WAIT,
WHAT?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Jon: I'M SORRY, JUST, CAN I
ASK A QUESTION. WHERE -- I'M
SORRY, MICHAEL. WHERE,
WHERE ARE YOU?
>> JON, I'M AS FAR AWAY FROM
THE SHOOT-ME STATE AS YOU CAN
GET. OK?
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S RIGHT.
NOTHING BUT SUN, SURFERS, AND
PALM TREES.
>> Jon: YOU'RE NOT IN LA, ARE
YOU? ARE YOU NEAR LA? BECAUSE
THEY, LAPD RECENTLY SHOT
AN UNARMED 25-YEAR-OLD
BLACK MAN TO DEATH, THEY WERE...
>> FOR REAL?
Jon: YEAH, I'M SORRY. IT JUST,
BUT IT DOESN'T MATTER, HERE IS
WHAT I WANT TO ASK YOU. WAIT A
MINUTE, WHERE ARE YOU NOW?
>> I'M IN THE SLEEPY SOUTH,
JON.
NOTHING TO FEAR IN CHARLOTTE,
NORTH CAROLINA.
HOME OF THE 2012 DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL CONVENTION -- YOU'RE
ABOUT TO TELL ME SOMETHING
TERRIBLE, AREN'T YOU?
>> Jon: NO, NO.
YES.
LAST YEAR CHARLOTTE POLICE
OFFICER GUNNED DOWN AN UNARMED
COLLEGE FOOTBALL PLAYER WHO
APPROACHED A WHITE WOMAN'S HOUSE
FOR HELP AFTER CRASHING HIS CAR,
AND [BLEEP] ALRIGHT... WHERE ARE
YOU GOING? WHERE ARE YOU
GOING? MICHAEL, WHERE ARE YOU
GOING? COME...
>> I GOTTA FIND A PLACE WHERE
THEY DON'T KILL SO MANY BLACK
PEOPLE. AND I AIN'T GOING THERE.
THEY KILLED A BLACK DUDE AT
KROGER. LITTLE ROCK? UNARMED
SENIOR CITIZEN. NO [BLEEP] FAIR
AT ALL. NOPE, NOT NEW ORLEANS.
THEY KILLED A KID IN A POT RAID.
OH, NOT THERE EITHER. DUDE
GOT SHOT IN HIS OWN DRIVEWAY
FOR WEARING BAGGY PANTS.
SHOT IN THE BACK WITH AN AR15.
KILLED FOR PICKING UP A BB GUN
IN WALMART. A [BLEEP] TOY BB
GUN!
>> Jon: NO, MICHAEL, GET OUT OF
THERE.
YOU'VE GOTTA GO SOMEWHERE SAFE,
MICHAEL! GO SOMEWHERE...
>> RELAX, JON.
>> Jon: ALRIGHT.
>> I'M NOT EVEN ON EARTH
ANYMORE.
NOWHERE IS SAFER FOR A BLACK MAN
THAN THE INFINITE BLACKNESS OF
OUTER SPACE.
(SIRENS).
>> AW MAN, YOU'VE GOT TO BE
[BEEP] KIDDING ME, MAN.
>> EXCUSE ME, SIR.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING IN THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD, YOU LIVE AROUND
HERE.
>> IT'S SPACE.
WE ALL LIVE AROUND HERE, SIR.
>> YEAH, THAT'S A
PRETTY EXPENSIVE LOOKING SPACE
HELMET THERE. YOU GOT A
RECEIPT FOR THAT THING?
>> ACTUALLY I DO.
>> WOAH, WOAH, WOAH, HANDS
WHERE I CAN SEE THEM. AND TAKE
THAT STOLEN HELMET OFF.
>> BUT I NEED THIS STOLEN HELMET
TO BREATHE.
I MEAN, MAN, I BOUGHT THIS
HELMET.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
STOLEN?
>> ALRIGHT, THAT'S IT, DOWN ON
THE GROUND.
DOWN ON THE GROUND.
>> THERE IS NO GROUND, IT'S
SPACE.
PLEASE JUST DON'T SHOOT
ME, MAN. PLEASE.
Jon: ALRIGHT, MICHAEL, JUST DO
WHAT HE SAYS.
WE'LL SEND YOU A LAWYER ON THE
NEXT ROCKET UP. HANG ON!
OH BOY! MICHAEL CHE, EVERYBODY.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
HANG IN THERE!